[Applause]
and finally new rule this year for
Valentine's Day let's celebrate the fact
that in-person meetups are finally
making a comeback yep
yep that's what I've been reading that
after years of being conditioned a
search out prospective mates by swiping
our phones singles are putting on pants
and heading out to places like grocery
stores parks and of course for
Republican Congressman the Old Reliable
truck stop restroom
foreign
at the upscale grocery chain here in L.A
called air one also known as shop and
Shag
it's reported that they purposefully
make the aisles narrow so that as you
squeeze by you feel People's Energy
in-person energy so retro
apparently even Home Depot has become
quite the pickup place the Home Depot
dating trend on Tick Tock has 3.6
billion views of women who I guess
regarded as the perfect venue to find
eligible men willing to work with their
hands
laughs
who cares if they're mostly illegal
aliens
as one woman wrote I'm headed to Home
Depot look confused confused in the
lumber aisle
ah a damsel in distressed genes and why
not even a not terribly bright guy can
figure out how to respond when a woman
or a gay man says excuse me I'm looking
to get some wood can you help me
but here's a little life tip for the men
if you want to get with a woman try this
trick talk to her
yeah
in person
because here's what's happened in the
last 10 years the phone ruined dating
and porn ruined sex
and women have been left with men who
don't know how to actually talk to a
woman anymore and who think first base
is anal and second base is choking
it's not surprising that women are
finally revolting Against The
Superficial scroll and swipe form of
dating that of course works for men who
are over sexed and disgusting and
biologically designed to seek the
maximum orgasms for the minimal amount
of work
today
dating apps took the worst inherent
traits of men and exacerbated them by a
multiple of infinity
let's see I'm horny I'm lazy I'm a
coward and I suck at honest
communication
is there a way I could have an
electronic Harem right in my hand
with the only answers are ever yes or
next
as far as effort goes it's one notch
above sticking your dick in the vacuum
cleaner
don't get me wrong technology is a
wonderful thing I was just saying that
the other day to my Japanese sex robot
[Applause]
R2 me too
but just because something is on your
phone doesn't mean it's better and
that's the lesson women should have
taken away from all this dating from the
phone took away any incentive for men to
cough up the two things women want from
them courage
and communication
the courage to step to her for real and
demonstrate your desire
enough to risk rejection and
communication women are communicative
creatures even when they're breaking up
with you they say we need to talk
[Applause]
we are endlessly hearing about girl
power and being a girl boss please
ladies you let the technology play you
and you got punked by your phone of
course Tinder is every guy's dream a
hookup Rolodex but it's the opposite of
what you want intimacy emotional
availability and being seen as a full
human being
I know we're all fluid and non-binary
and totally free and super Brave now but
here's the thing we're not
not mostly
women haven't changed that much you know
how I know this because the bachelor is
still on
foreign
[Applause]
Bachelor in Paradise are you the one
perfect match Joe Millionaire farmer
wants a wife the courtship the Real Love
Boat Cosmic Love Love In the Jungle Love
on the Spectrum Love is Blind love
Island Temptation Island and MILF Manor
okay great
not MILF matter take that one off
that is some sick that but the
other thousand shows where women still
want the Roses the romance and the
commitment should tell you something
they don't
plant emoji and a text at one in the
morning what's up
they want you to compliment their hair
notice what they're wearing and hear
about their day
I know it's a nightmare
but it's still better than the incel
life of having a fake girlfriend on only
fans and paying rent to your mom
so let's build on this budding trend of
doing it in person let's hearken back to
that time when the mirror wasn't just
for selfies
but to make sure you didn't look like
when you left the house
let's remember that at one time
stout-hearted Americans roamed this
continent and mated face to face and
that's why so much of America today is
named after these Intrepid horndogs
places like romance Arkansas and
Intercourse Pennsylvania
Bumpass Virginia and Morehead Kentucky
ball play Alabama and three-way Arizona
horny Town North Carolina boneville in
Georgia and ramtown in New Jersey
spunk Creek Minnesota and hump Mountain
West Virginia
to name just a few we did it before and
we can do it again Happy Valentine's Day
everybody